[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Today
I'm in the Big Apple
meeting with Josh
Gordon from Google
to talk about machine
learning, where
we will dig into how it
works, why it's important,
and where you can
learn all about it.
Welcome to Coffee with a
Googler in New York City.
I'm Laurence Moroney,
and I'm here today
speaking with Joshua Gordon.
Now, it's something
that a lot of people
don't really understand
what machine learning is
in a concrete manner.
JOSHUA GORDON: So
machine learning
is all about learning
from examples
rather than writing
manual rules.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
JOSHUA GORDON: So the
short way of saying
that is regular programming is
you write a lot of manual rules
to solve a problem.
In machine learning,
you let the algorithm
find those rules for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
JOSHUA GORDON: From examples.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So pattern matching.
It might be visual, or it
might be other patterns
that are hidden in data.
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
And so the input to machine-- so
the beauty of machine learning,
and the real secret sauce,
is that an algorithm that
learns patterns from
data can solve thousands
of different problems.
And the reason is if I write
a Python program to recognize
digits, my program is hard
coded to work with digits.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
JOSHUA GORDON: But if I write
an algorithm to learn patterns
from data, I can use that
for speech recognition, image
recognition, medicine.
Basically, anything that
you can start with examples,
just tell apart A and B, my
same algorithm that I wrote just
once can tackle
all these problems.
And that's a really special and
actually fairly profound thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
Now, one of the things in
your classes that you're
talking about that you're
starting with language.
You're starting with
Java and Python,
I think it was, that you said?
JOSHUA GORDON: Yes, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So how's the class
going to be
structured for people
who want to be these data
scientists of the future?
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
So first of all, there
are zero prerequisites.
Well, that's not true.
There's one prerequisite.
LAURENCE MORONEY: My favorite.
Oh, OK.
Well, what's the one prereq?
JOSHUA GORDON: Basic programming
ability in Java or Python.
And by basic, I mean you can run
scripts and you can tweak them.
That's it.
A little bit of
high school math.
And that means like basic
algebra, basic geometry.
When I say basic geometry,
to be totally honest,
if you asked me, like,
what sine and cosine,
I would have to Google it.
I don't remember, honestly.
So just basic familiarity,
and that's it.
And we're going to teach
the class in three ways.
We're going to teach it
totally from the ground up.
So one problem I had with some
of the academic classes I took
is that they'll talk
about a fancy algorithm,
like neural
networks, but they'll
talk about it in terms of math.
And so at the end of the class,
I don't know how to build that.
I can't really do it.
We're doing it in a reverse way.
We're building it step
by step, and we're
explaining only the math that's
really necessary as we go.
And instead of equations, we're
going use visual examples.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Perfect.
JOSHUA GORDON: So
an equation could
be like if you talk
about gradient descent,
gradient descent
basically means finding
the minimum of a function.
So if I just say that, like as a
developer, I'm like, all right,
what does that mean?
So you can think
of any equation,
like x cubed plus y squared
plus whatever equals 7.
There's some value of x and y.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's going
to be the bottom of that curve,
right?
JOSHUA GORDON: Or not equals 7.
Equals some value.
Right.
Anyway, you can find
the bottom of that curve
literally by thinking as a bowl.
You can drop a piece
of fruit in a bowl
and it will roll to the bottom.
And gradient descent
just means finding
where this function is 0.
And you can actually
describe that really simply
in only like 10 or
12 lines of Python,
actually, instead of
five slides of equations.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I think it's also
important to understand
why you need to find
the bottom of the curve.
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And just
focus on that example.
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
So that's difficult
to describe concisely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
JOSHUA GORDON: So
in machine learning,
let's say you're
writing an algorithm.
Let's say it's to distinguish
apples from oranges.
You always want to know, how
accurate is my algorithm?
Like, I can solve that
problem in one line.
I can just say,
return math.random.
So one line, math.random.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
would be the perfect one.
JOSHUA GORDON: My
accuracy is crap.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 50%.
JOSHUA GORDON: Right.
Yeah, it's 50%.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Between
an apple and an orange.
JOSHUA GORDON: It's a one liner.
But really, we want
to get-- another way
of describing accuracy
is you can think
about it n terms of error.
High accuracy means low error.
And you can have an equation
that describes your error.
And the minimum of
that equation is
going to give you
the highest accuracy.
So you can write your
machine learning algorithm
to try and minimize the equation
that describes the error.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
JOSHUA GORDON: And we'll
make that super concrete
in the class, but that's
where minimization comes in
and that's where gradient
descent comes in.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So one of the things
you're saying in
the class, you're
teaching just a pure
Java, Python version.
But there's also a
version where you're
bringing in
preexisting libraries
that have come from academia.
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That will
solve a lot of this for you,
right?
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
So I want to do a couple things.
One is I want to
provide the TLDR.
So honestly, as a
developer, I like to get up
and running really fast.
So we're also going to use
open source libraries from just
different universities.
There's one in New Zealand
that I really love.
We're going to you how to build,
basically first, everything
from the ground up step
by step from scratch.
And the reason we do that is
because it keeps us honest.
If you build every
single piece, you
have some understanding
of every single piece.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And if
you're relying on somebody else
having done the work, you don't
fully get to understand it
yourself.
JOSHUA GORDON: Exactly.
Now, another thing is using
the open source libraries,
honestly, you can solve
probably 80% or 90%
of the machine learning problems
you would as a data scientist.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
JOSHUA GORDON: Now, when you
get to the really gigantic
problems, then really it
makes sense to use the cloud.
So we're also going
to teach how to solve
problems using Google APIs.
But that's at the
very end of the class,
and it's totally optional.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
is all on YouTube, right?
JOSHUA GORDON: All on YouTube.
There might be some ads on
it, but that's literally it.
We think it's going
to be awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Like
source code and stuff
that you've done?
JOSHUA GORDON: The source
code will be on GitHub.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's all on GitHub.
Perfect.
JOSHUA GORDON: It
will all be on GitHub.
And the reason I
was hesitating is
I'm writing all this
as we're speaking,
so I'm totally exhausted.
But yes, it's totally,
100% out there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well, you're
still looking energetic to me.
JOSHUA GORDON: I've had a
lot of coffee with a Googler.
Good for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well, I for one
am really looking
forward to this course.
I'm looking forward to learning
what you have to teach.
I've had the same
kind of struggles
as you in trying to understand
the math behind this
and why I'm doing
the math, which
is why I had those
pointed questions earlier.
JOSHUA GORDON: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So thanks, Josh.
That was a whole lot of fun.
And I've learned so
much about machine
learning just from these
few minutes with you,
so I'm really looking
forward to your class.
JOSHUA GORDON: Thanks so much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: If you've
enjoyed this episode of Coffee
with a Googler and if you
want to learn machine learning
for yourself, if you have
any questions for Joshua,
or if you've any
questions for me,
please leave them in
the comments below.
And tune into the Google
Developers channel
for more great videos,
including episodes
of Coffee with a Googler.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA GORDON: You really
can learn machine learning,
and it's faster and
easier than you think.
We've gone through a ton of
classes, textbooks, and blog
posts to bring you the clearest
and most concise explanations
of the hard concepts.
We really think you're going
to be able to learn it and have
some fun on the way.
Click here to get started.